please welcome miss laura dern
just the art of acting is at its best
when the audience is unaware of the
technique so the art of filmmaking is
most impressive when the scenes aren't
showing and the persons who labor long
and hard in scientific laboratories to
put the art in the state of the art are
the members of the scientific and
technological community in a special
ceremony I had the honor of hosting last
month
these behind-the-scenes artists and
craftspeople honored their peers for the
exceptional work done this past year to
make the making of movies even more
magical and manageable here are some
moments from that special evening
awards of Merit were accepted by
panavision's president John Ferrand for
their anamorphic lenses and Manfred G
Michelson of technical film systems for
his ultra high-speed film transport
system the highest technical award named
for Gordon Sawyer this year went to a
man whose achievements include
developments in many fields such as the
camera crane controller the high gain
driving projection screen and the
traveling matte system the recipient was
Petro Vlahos I want to thank the Board
of Governors and the scientific and take
the worst committee for this Gordon E
Sawyer lifetime achievement award it has
a special meaning for me because it
represents a commendation by my fellow
engineers and also because it honors the
memory of Gordon Sawyer a friend of many
years and a pioneer in motion picture
technology thank you
the Academy extends its congratulations
to all the members of the scientific and
technological community who have
advanced the cause of filmmaking and
been recognized with the Oscar thank you
Thank You Lora you know the scientific
and technical Awards would have been
brought to you live tonight but we're
experiencing technical difficulties I'd
like to take this moment to point out
some of my friends who are with us
tonight Steven Spielberg and Richard
Dreyfuss and this miss Houston hey girl
you know we don't have a statue for you
here tonight but you know what you know
now you see why they only let me sing
with knives